well this month Bangladesh ratified the
Hong Kong Convention for the safe and
sustainable recycling of ships its big
business in Bangladesh but rights
organizations have long voiced concerns
about dangerous conditions for workers
as well as environmental damage Danver
Chowdhury reports from sitakunda near
the Bay of Bengal
Bangladesh is one of the world's biggest
hubs for ship recycling after vessels
are decommissioned they're broken down
and the pots are repurposed guidelines
from the international Maritime
organization known as the Hong Kong
Convention include ways of limiting risk
to human health and safety and to the
environment some recycling yards are
already complying with the convention
within next two years all the yards in
Bangladesh will reach the Hong Kong
Convention level and it will be a strong
message to the world that send your
vessels to Bangladesh and it will be
responsibly recycled
Bangladesh's cheap labor makes it a
popular destination for ships at the end
of their operational lives
the sector generates substantial income
an estimated 2 billion dollars in 2022
and creates many jobs with the Boom in
construction there is an increasing
demand for Iron and Steel and the scrap
metal from these dismantle shapes are
one of the main sources
but according to the international labor
organization the industry is among the
most dangerous in the world with high
fatality rates injuries and workplace
related diseases
some employees we spoke to are unhappy
but didn't want it to be identified for
fear of repercussions
it'd be good if we could have proper
safety gear and a clean working
environment then there'd be less chance
of any accidents happening
working conditions are better than
before but workers are treated badly we
don't get a decent wage or proper Health
Care compensation for all the hard labor
advocacy groups are loving for improved
working conditions we really appreciate
Bangladesh government has approved the
Hong Kong Convention we also appreciate
some of the progressive owners developed
their yard as grignard but the concern
is there are many years who are not
following the convention
the international labor organization
says employees need Union representation
to protect their rights and workplace
safety committees to ensure they have
the power to refuse dangerous jobs
Chinese
who's a lawyer of the Bangladesh Supreme
Court with more than 20 years experience
she advocates for Environmental
Protection joining us live from DACA
welcome to Al Jazeera so as we heard in
tanvir's package while reaping economic
benefits for the country there are still
significant environmental concerns as
well as concerns when it comes to
workplace related issues so in your
opinion how much progress has been made
in addressing these concerns
um thank you very much I don't think
much progress has been made I think
um the efforts that we see are largely
artificial and the efforts have been
taken to impress upon the global coming
and look there in some years there have
been development so we are now a safe
hop I can give you just one statistic in
the first six months this year when
import of sheep has actually slowed down
in Bangladesh because of the economic
recession we have already lost three
lives and I am dealing with 40 workers
who we suspect have got asbestosis so I
don't think General Improvement has
taken please I think some years have
taken some improvement measures which I
would consider seriously artificial
where the reason is all 15 years that we
have in Bangladesh are on the beaches
okay let me ask you this then in your
opinion what will it take for the sector
to remain competitive yet
environmentally sustainable and safer
workers
for it to be environmentally sustainable
labor safe and at the same time to be
economically viable I think every player
involved in the sector has to be very
honest it's an international trade so
the Sheep owners have to be honest the
exporting country has to be honest in
providing the inventory of hazardous
material the importing country has to be
honest in ensuring that it does not
import vessel when it does not have an
environmental sound management we have
to ensure that the cash barriers are
accountable one has to understand the
very simple fact that if National laws
do not work international law will also
not work because the monitoring
mechanism in international law is much
weaker than the monitoring mechanism in
National laws that's what I wanted to
ask you about in fact what sort of
monitoring mechanisms are there in place
to see whether compliance is being
achieved
I would say that the shipwrecking
industry as it is operating now it's a
classic place of global corruption and
Global hypocrisy so I I don't see any
many monitoring mechanism here in
Bangladesh and the monitoring mechanism
that the Hong Kong Convention prescribes
it basically puts the fox in charge of
the chicken so I don't think any
significant uh Improvement will take
place it will only be covering up the
illegalities the bitching method the
flag of spontaneous and the weaknesses
in the downstream uh West management
with some green certificate I'm not very
hopeful okay we'll have to leave it
there we thank you so much for joining
us from Dhaka